[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we
sift through philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use
in your everyday life hi i'm dan i'm
joined by my co-host dr greg sadler
and today we're talking about studying
philosophy outside traditional
academia and this is kind of a long
overdue episode i think for for us
as we were talking about it actually
texting about it
uh earlier was that last week that we
were doing that
you know it's it's something that we've
been touching on
over and over and over again but we
never really
settled down to talk about it as a
particular topic and then when i texted
it to you you said oh that's a great
idea
we should do it and then i it's one of
those sort of things where
until you actually put it there on the
table
you don't you don't realize that it's
something you should have been doing
this entire time right
but then once you do it clicks and so
that's
that's what we're going to do today
and this is kind of a cool way to do it
you know dan
and i both are people who went to
college so we got to
experience philosophy you could say in
in that traditional
academic setting but we both have a lot
of background
outside of traditional academia as well
and you know i i've always kept one foot
in the the old academic what do we want
to call it wash basin or
something like institution there you go
and dan you know forged a whole
different path and
uh came back to philosophy was it was it
primarily through
studying stoicism or was it something
else before that
um there was a little yeah i think it
was
first stoicism at as well as like the
last
semester or two of my actual academic
career i started getting into
it in a more systematic way or like it
was like
my interest was extremely peaked
okay uh actually before we jump into
this
let me ask because you know when you say
your interest gets peaked there's
multiple ways that can happen
for people one would be like the subject
material itself is just compelling
no matter who's teaching it or
introducing it to you even if it's a bad
teacher you're like well i want to keep
studying this because this is cool
but was there i mean this is something
we've never actually talked about did
you have any professors or
instructors who you know really got you
into
this stuff where because they were
competent
and and interested in the things they
managed to drag you along
no i think it was mostly ideas
like i don't want to dismiss any of my
professors
i found all of them to be rather
competent but i
i've never been wrapped i guess the only
the only person that's
or one of the few people kind of funnily
that has
wrapped my attention into a topic was i
took
accounting and for some reason like i
would have never taken another
accounting class if it was not for the
professor that i had
actually at matc many many years ago i
think that makes a really
huge impact on a lot of students the
the ways in which the professors present
the material
in ways that the students can grasp can
see the
importance of it and also you know
convey a kind of passion for it
right accounting is not something you
think people would be passionate about
but
you know people can be you know my dad
was a tax attorney
and he you know i i looked through some
of his old books
uh both law and accounting books and
they seem very dry to me but he
he could get quite excited about it you
know so
i think being able to convey something
of that uh it's not the only thing
obviously
but right it makes us same question for
you what was the thing that
immediately piqued your interest in
philosophy
yeah well uh i think i may have talked
about this on the show before
i had a terrible philosophy class in
high school
which then was followed by a class that
was not labeled as a philosophy class it
was actually a religion class
sacraments but it was taught by a guy
who was
a replacement teacher and he taught it
as a philosophy class introducing us
to augustine and then saying well if i'm
going to teach you augustine i got to
teach you some plato and some aristotle
and he taught it in a philosophical way
where there was lots of dialogue and you
know
knocking ideas around and seeing what
would fall out of them rather than
the previous guy was just like memorize
the stuff in this this dry
text you know and he didn't like anyone
to
um raise any issues or questions
so that was you know it was a really
interesting contrast and then you know
when i got to college
i think i again i think i've told this
story before
my mom's boyfriend at the time
actually her old boyfriend because it
was a different boyfriend who got who
suggested i go to that college and i
didn't know anything you know so
um you were a tabula rasa there
kind of the old the old boyfriend um
said declare a major immediately and
then you won't be
just you know one freshman lost in the
crowd so i looked down the whole list of
stuff and i was like philosophy that
sounds cool i'll do that
and i just kept going with it you know
so there wasn't like
and actually my professors in college
the philosophy professors they weren't
very good at all you know
graduate school they were great but but
yeah our our philosophy professors at
lakeland at that time college now
university which no longer has a
philosophy program
they were like 20 years past their prime
and
not very interested in what they were
teaching and so
i i you know i had a really great
experience of what what i've come to
call benign neglect
[Laughter]
allow you to do a little bit of your own
self
uh directed learning there they did yeah
i got super into existentialism and they
were like yeah go ahead go do that you
know
go read some books in the library and
write a paper i don't know if i'll read
it or not
you know but you go ahead and write it
and
so that's academic philosophy that we're
talking about
about there obviously not everybody's
experience is quite
like that but yeah so
coming back to where we we started this
this is a topic that we've been kind of
circling around for a long time
philosophy is really central in this
show
um you know we dan and i both think that
philosophy
is something that ordinary people can
apply in their lives to
to make them better that's why we
started the show in the first place so
um now it's about time we actually talk
about where do you find resources
for doing that right uh
right but also i wanted to add here that
you know
the whole one of the points that we're
talking about this and why we're doing
this and
and our different experiences within
academia
in relation to philosophy it shows that
not everyone can or should study
philosophy
in this traditional academic setting it
might not be
the best way for you to actually
introduce yourself to these ideas
yeah that's that's actually a great
point because i think a lot of people
feel like unless they're in a
traditional academic program they're
kind of missing out on something
you know and maybe that was the case you
know
at one point in time but it's definitely
not the case today for reasons that
we'll
we'll talk about in just a few minutes
yeah there's also this uh idea of this
um it being opaque and it's like how do
you even enter into it
you know this is a little bit of a
digression
um in the 19 you can tell this by the
way that people talked about philosophy
in the 60s 70s and 80s
there was this tendency in both european
philosophy
and anglo-american philosophy to make
philosophy very elitist
for the most part there were there were
some outliers who were doing something
different
but there was this tendency to be like
oh you're not smart enough for that you
know you go study economics or you
go study computer science or you know if
philosophy that's for the real
brains and you wouldn't you wouldn't
understand what we're doing
so you know just go over there and do
your
your thing right and that was a stupid
stupid
way to behave in part they came to
realize this because
when um in the 90s and 2000s people
started saying oh well what do you
actually contribute philosophy
why should we be paying money for you
all these philosophy professors who are
you know at that point in like chairs
and deans they didn't have any answer
they'd be like well they're
the intrinsic value of the the
experience or stuff like that and then
they'd say
that there's no cash value in that so
we're going to close
your department down and we're going to
shrink the number of professors that you
have
and not being able to provide an answer
because they essentially talk themselves
out of an answer for several generations
not being able to provide an answer to
the question what do you actually do and
why should we care about what you do
that was a killer and it's still taking
its toll on philosophy departments today
i think
yeah and i think that is definitely a
topic for another show
yeah so let's talk about some of the
benefits of
studying philosophy we wanted to convey
this at the start and there's some
some general benefits that you know
everybody can
partake in um dan you you've got some
that you wanted to call attention to
yeah so you know we're living in this
a new world where you know in
decades past you like turn on the
nightly news and you could feel
rather uh confident that the information
that you were being presented
you know by your um who's the guys the
good
oh walnut yeah cronkite you know like
that was
as close to the truth as you could
possibly potentially get at the moment
for the the issues of the day
but now we have such a bombardment of
different information that is being
presented
to us that becomes really difficult to
actually parse out what is
truth and what is opinion and what is um
intentional mistruth and so
uh within the
grand scheme of philosophy there is a
subset called epistemology which is the
study of knowledge
how one um obtains knowledge and how one
like
sifts through what information can be
true or not
and that is becoming a more and more
necessary tool in one's tool belt in
order to actually
navigate the world in a way that
actually gives you some
true impressions yeah i i think it it
it's it's interesting because
back in the day we used to like look at
epistemology as
um ah that's nice you know let's jump
now into the real substantive stuff
and when i say we i don't mean every
philosopher obviously there were a lot
of people really interested in
epistemology but
but i think dana's right it's taking on
a much
greater importance weight however we
want to put it
um if we are epistemologically naive
we're
really screwed in in today's media
saturated environment
especially like not even you don't even
have to have like bad actors
um just that we have so many cognitive
biases
yeah that we unknowingly just like oh
well like
there's the whole thing um it's it's
hard for someone to
understand something that he's paid to
not understand
yeah like if it works against my best
interest i don't want to actually
believe that like
i don't know lead in gasoline is
actually uh causing neurological damage
to basically every human in the united
states and so i'm going to fight against
that i'm not going to believe that
that's true you know and you know i'm
older than you i remember when the
the changeover came and there were
indeed a lot of people who were
mad about it and and we could take all
sorts of automotive things oh those seat
belts
they're gonna make laws and the seat
belts are gonna trap us and kill us and
people would say all sorts of crazy
stuff like that um
with every single change airbags the
airbags are gonna kill us
yeah i would say you know is there
anything anymore you want to say about
epistemology
no i think that that that gives you like
unless there's a resource of like
thinking fast and slow as a book
that just kind of like lays out yeah
many tens of different uh human biases
that we all have and it's
really hard to not fall into them i like
that you
identified like common uses
of an academic subject within philosophy
epistemology
and so i'm going to bring up a couple
other you know terms like that that we
we generally parse out into whole like
classes or curriculum
in philosophy metaphysics you know what
what
is real and what's fake you know that's
that's a metaphysical question
and we don't we often don't um frame
these in very rigorous ways but
philosophy can
help us to to dig around in that or
what's human nature is there
a human nature you know is there
something that we all have in common
that's a metaphysical question and you
know we can also talk about ethics which
is a huge field
i think that that studying ethics can be
very helpful for people
even if it doesn't provide them with
exact answers to things it like helps
them
learn how to figure out what question
they should be asking
you know or how to screw how to fix
things after they've screwed them up
that that's a big part of ethics
actually
how to get yourself back on track and
you know another one that doesn't get a
lot of
talk but i think all of us are
engaged in at one point or another when
we use words like that's cool
or you really ought to watch that movie
or things like that aesthetics
you know what what makes things not just
you know the old
aesthetics oh what's art what's beauty
what makes things beautiful but but you
know asking questions like well is this
is this a good use of my time to binge
watch this series i think in a lot of
cases that's not just an ethical
question that's that's an aesthetic
question
you know why should i watch so recently
uh andy and i watched our way through
the americans which i keep calling the
russians because they're actually
russian spies you know
um but it was a good series you know
asking yourself well what makes that
series good and worth watching as
opposed to that other schlock
that you could be watching on netflix
hulu
you know pick whatever streaming service
you want
you know those are those are really
important questions i think
and how how do you come to those
conclusions yeah
not everyone's aesthetics are the
stamens so you have to like
have proxies that might tell you like
well yeah some people have poor taste
yeah but what is that right
all right how do you know it
is that a purely subjective question it
could be me too maybe i'm the one with
bad taste you know yeah
um please
i was just gonna say like um you you
i really like that you brought up one of
these questions about ethics of coming
back like once you've screwed something
up
i think that's actually kind of a big
question that's that's
pertinent to the the current zeitgeist
of
um you know people screw up and and what
what is the process
that one needs to get back into the good
graces of
one's community and uh it feels like
that is
a little bit out of whack and i feel
like that is definitely some place that
we can
investigate and actually come up with
some like at least guidelines
yeah that that's true there's um there's
a whole
subdivision of ethics called the ethics
of apologies
where they parse out like what what a
good apology should include and
and usually they look at like ceos of
companies that have screwed up as like
examples of bad apologies or they're
like
you know mistakes were made nobody
really wanted any of this to happen
all right we're done here you know um
that's not a very good apology you know
there's more
involved in that so philosophy can help
us
understand those those sort of uh issues
and questions you know that that
everyday people have to face
right hey so why why are you
so particularly interested in this this
topic of
how to get resources how to study
philosophy outside of academia
uh okay so the whole point of this show
is that we can use like the wisdom of
the ages in philosophy to make
our lives better for those around us and
ourselves and that's
i think a very uh a nobel noble
um a goal to have
to like i i would like to give back to
the world a little bit about that
yeah i mean you've experienced some of
that right so is this
is this like a paying it forward thing
for you or
there's definitely a certain amount of
extent to that yeah um
you know i i was you know
like you had uh anger issues early in my
life and then i had
um i calmed down a little bit by college
by the time that i was
about then i had to deal with some
really negative uh
social experiences and and then i found
you know stoicism that allowed me to
deal with these in a lot
more productive way and so that was
definitely something that like
pulled me deeper into this it's like oh
like there is something here that is
actually beneficial that i
i want to explore as much as possible um
because it's already giving me such
benefits and yeah i'd like to have
other people have those benefits if they
are willing
yeah there is something that's something
that's talked about too by the way in in
ancient philosophy and medieval
philosophy quite a bit that when you
when you have a good a good communicates
itself you know
if you know that something is good for
you and you're a decent human being you
want to be
not just your own private like totally
walled off thing
but you want to share it with others uh
to improve their lives that's that's
part of our social nature you could say
you know and for you greg
well you know i've i've had a lot of
experience
over the years with living a kind of
double life
you know i was a full-time
philosophy professor and assistant
professor at ball state university when
i taught in the prisons and then at
fayetteville state university
and then i i began you know i moved up
to new york and i i started adjuncting
and doing other things and early on i
started getting involved with like you
know
the the early 2010s were this time of
like
everybody bringing out a new educational
platform that was going to like change
everything there was moocs and there
were like you know
i got involved in a whole bunch of
educational startups
um most of which failed which like most
other startups right surprise surprise
um
and they are all going to like totally
revolutionize things and and they made
me
think about well how do you how do you
do philosophy with with
um regular people rather than in
strictly academic settings and so i
found i really like that
stuff you know and then there was also
like you know the youtube channel and
other things as well so
i saw that there was
this really deep hunger out there
for substantive engagement with ideas
not just
you know spoon fed let's make every
dumbing down is what people would often
say right
ordinary people not everybody but but a
lot of people
really wanted to you know to learn
things
and not just learn trivial things but to
learn important things and
those needs weren't being met by the
entertainment and news industry that we
have our traditional media
and they weren't being met by
universities and colleges either
because they you know they might put on
a occasional talk for
local people to come into and then
contribute some money to the department
or whatever
but they they weren't doing any real
effective outreach and so
when i would when i did my own kind of
let's
say it you know kind of made up on the
fly and sometimes half-assed kind of uh
outreach of my own you know kind of just
seeing what
would work out there was a very positive
response
you know people would like watch my my
videos that weren't
in my view particularly well produced
and they'd be like this is amazing you
know
i i can't go to college but now this
makes me feel like i'm participating in
a classroom or i'd go and give a talk at
a library and people would come up
afterwards and they'd say
thanks so much for for uh doing this you
know nobody else is doing it
so i i kind of think that there's
something out there that we could
contribute to and when i say you know we
you and me
dan we're just like you know one little
node and a whole bunch of other
nodes but we can all do our part in
making
this is going to sound kind of trivial
uh you know but making a better world
making a world in which people can
actually study philosophy without
feeling
like gatekeepers are blocking them or
you know that if they say the wrong
thing they're going to get thrown out of
the room you know where they can learn
where they can
where they can develop you know yeah i i
feel that strongly
you know i i feel
strongly because like i uh went and
audited a couple of courses
after i was done with the university and
i only had that
opportunity because of where i happened
to be in my life
but that anyone that's working in nine
to five would not have had that
opportunity whatsoever
and and i i found such great value from
taking these uh extra philosophy courses
just as
you know as an audit of these that um
you were providing that that i wouldn't
have had if i was in a traditional job
at that moment in time
yeah you know going back to like moocs
i i you probably remember them right
earlier they're still around
yeah you know the the big problem with
moocs was that people
thought like all our eggs should go into
that one basket
and as it turned out they weren't a very
good way of delivering content
outside of certain subject areas like if
you're doing coding
and computer science they were pretty
successful if you're trying to teach
history the completion rates were
abysmal you know or other divergent
subjects like that
but for the people who did them you know
and and saw them through
it were pretty good you know it just
went to show that we
you know we need to avoid messianic
stuff and
look be much more pragmatic look for
what what actually works what meets
people's
needs and desires and and uh helps them
develop we should we should talk about
what we mean by traditional academic
we've been throwing this term around
quite a lot you mean the ivory castle
right or the ivory tower
the ivory castle with all the ivory
towers
yeah i mean and i mentioned you know i
used that word gatekeeping right
it's that's part of a castle too you got
to get around the moat and go down you
know
get yourself in the drawbridge you know
for for
the way people typically think of
college education
it's something you pay for and pay a lot
for
unless you you know get a uh in the
movies they always get a scholarship and
the scholarship covers everything these
scholarships hardly ever cover
everything um you know and and you take
the classes that they
they give and it's very much a crapshoot
you know the the dirty little secret of
academia is
you don't know anything about the
institution until you actually spend
some time
within it and things vary wildly not
just from one college or university to
another
but within it from one department to
another from one professor to another
from one class to another
and so you know you can go to you can go
to harvard and you can shell out tons
and tons of money
and have a terrible educational
experience and you can go to
um you know we'll just take some of the
local milwaukee institutions you can go
to marquette
and have a decent experience but you
might actually have had a better
experience going to cardinal stritch or
going to
uw-milwaukee or going to matc you know
it really depends so much on what is
being put
in front of you and there's there's
really there's there's no consistent
quality control
you could say and then and there can't
add
yeah and then you add on top of it like
the
the student organizations can really
also make or break in like the community
of the students
and those those are constantly in flux
like any string
organization has a memory of about four
years and so
this thing goes yeah
like with philosophy we'd be talking
about like philosophy clubs
right and that's always dependent on
some go-getter students
who hopefully are not having a bad you
know romantic relationship or
death in the family or anything like
that to do all the the groundwork and
then they have to have a faculty advisor
who may be doing it just to get you know
a service line on their vita or because
they really care about it
you know a little bit of a digression
here
when i was at marist college there were
two
people in the department who saw the
writing on the wall that if they didn't
like
boost the number of majors there'd
probably be some cuts
and those two really did a lot of work
and they had
60 philosophy majors by the time that i
left there
for a small liberal arts school that's a
lot
you know so you know that contributes to
a nice environment but how do you know
that you're going to get that
you don't you know and most people
still today can't participate in that
they don't have the money
they don't have the available time
they've got other commitments like
children or you know
caretaking or whatever it's going to be
what is the life of contemplation if
you've got three kids in a 40 hour
a week job if not two you don't have a
life of contemplation if you have three
kids
unless you train them really well
[Laughter]
so you know there's uh there's also a
lot of adult education
you know auditing dan mentioned
auditing is when you go to a class and
you're actually taking the class but
you're not taking it for credit and so
you don't have to complete the
assignments but you get the
the class experience right and that's
nice if you can get it but
it's got to fit your schedule you know
most classes are in the middle of the
day
that's true yeah because most professors
want to teach their class
you know like a regular job
so you know the contemporary academic
setting is just one
of many different possible settings and
models
for studying philosophy engaging with
others
and it's it's not something that
historically was the norm
you know people have studied philosophy
outside of traditional um
accredited credentialing settings for
thousands of years you know they also
did study in like aristotle's lyceum or
um plato's academy but you could you
could also
you know wander around with croatia the
cynic and he'd teach you some stuff
while you're
scrounging or you know i guess
there's still a little bit of um that
you can see a lot of uh at least
flossie's way of life in a lot of like
martial arts studios
and so they there's this combination of
working the body and the mind um there's
there's a couple other places you know
you can definitely there's a
an aspect of that in many religious
organizations like there's
uh you know a philosophy and morality
that are just different
and distinct between like buddhism or
christianity or
you know take your pick there's always
there's almost always a
philosophy of life that is associated
with them
that's true and and actually we should
talk about like philosophy
there's like philosophy in a narrow
sense traditional academic philosophy
which most likely doesn't even include
you know half of what we could call
philosophy like if you want to study
hana or rent you're probably not going
to do that in a philosophy department
you're probably more likely to do that
in a political science department same
thing with alexis de tocqueville
if you want to study
you know some continental thinkers and
your philosophy department is analytic
well then you got to go over to the
english department or the red cop
department or
pick whoever right so um
there's there's a lot of of scope for
widening
your um what would we call it like you
know what makes philosophy available by
going to other
other places you know right
to be a little bit eclectic to actually
see the full breath that is what is
available to you
yeah actually i think you know we should
um
we should maybe we were going to talk a
little bit about this issue of public
philosophy but
maybe we'll we'll save that for another
time
and talk about you know what it is that
that learners want and need
and um then we'll jump into resources
because we really do want to key you
into a bunch of resources that are right
that are out there um so there's so
go ahead the big difference between like
those people that
want a a potentially a really clearly
defined
program um and that's i guess one of the
things that you would get if you go to a
traditional academic philosophy is like
well here are the classes and you're
gonna
you might have like well you gotta take
ethics first and some logic and
and then we'll start getting into the
more esoteric and and whatnot but like
at least there's there's a prescribed
course
and you can get this at least in a more
layman a way with the great courses
i guess could you tell me a little bit
about that i'm actually there a company
that um commissions
academics primarily to create courses
and then at first they sold them i think
like on
vhs cassettes you know and then now of
course it's like dvds and stuff like
that
recently massimo pigliucci did one on
stoicism
um you got to be kind of a big name to
or have some juice
or connections to get invited by them
and it's you know it's very much a
program right you you
go through it in the steps that they
want you to here's lesson one now here's
lesson two now here's lesson three
and that that's great for some people
you know um
so you can coursework with them no no i
mean
a lot of these sort of things will give
you writing prompts
or you know you discussion questions
like if you're using
them with a group you know you could ask
questions and
but they don't they don't um
they don't as far as i know do any of
that sort of
curricula stuff where you're completing
exercises and then they're grading them
um but oh go ahead
like the downside of this is that you're
kind of walking through this with
blinders on you can see exactly what
they are presenting to you
but you know there there is a whole
breath
of philosophical flora and fada that are
just
outside of your view to
to take in and to investigate but those
might not be
ever presented to you yeah and and you
don't know whether they've
got it right and here's the answer
nobody's actually got it right on
exactly what philosophy stuff you have
to
study you know they'll all try to tell
you that they do but
um the diversity of perspectives
gives you the idea that maybe nobody
actually knows you know
um and then there's you know other
people are a little bit more
independent they just want somebody
who's going to be like a guide or they
want to be in a community that suggests
things but but then leaves it
up to them and says hey if you like this
try this out but you don't have to
you know we're going to have a
discussion group on this over here
um that's you know like what we do in
our stoic fellowship right
we've got a couple different things
going on this is pretty common
you know if you want to study cicero's
uh on duties we're doing that
what are you doing in the sunday groups
um we are
uh finishing up a uh
basically section by section of the
enchiridion
okay deep discussion so yeah the
sections are all of like
two paragraphs at most and so we we
somehow
get an hours worth of content from three
of those sections
very rich text right oh yes so you know
you
if somebody wants to do that they can do
that if they don't want to show up for
one of those things that's cool too
nobody's going to like you know give
them a dirty look when they come back
so i'm so happy when people come back
after they've been gone a couple of
years like oh yeah you've been back
it's amazing someone a new person or a
person i know that i get to talk to
again
that's another important aspect of it
that i think
you know often gets overlooked do we
want to study philosophy
you know you use the word ivory tower it
could also be like the hermit's hut
you know uh like like heidegger's hut in
the black forest
everyone get the hell away from me i'm
with my books
well i mean that's cool for some people
but
that's not the way i like to study
philosophy
i kind of like to talk with other people
about it
and that dialogue is a very traditional
way of actually studying philosophy well
it doesn't i'm not going to
fall into the um the pitfall is saying
that oh just because it's traditional it
is good or the best or the only way of
doing that
but it is definitely a a widely
prescribed and
and for a very long time used way of
doing this
yeah that's that's quite true you know
interestingly
when socrates and then plato picking up
on him and you know there were other
people who who wrote socratic dialogues
xenophon
eskinese who we don't have anymore um
that was an innovation right because the
traditional way of
teaching before that was not through
question and answer it was through i'm
gonna talk
you're gonna listen i'm i'm the the
speech maker
now you sit and see what i have to say
but you're right it turned into
a tradition of its own type
where people are like well must be good
because it's old you know
but i would love to
like you know shout the the
greatness of the segment because instead
of like i'm just gonna sit here and
lecture at you
we get to dig into these ideas
and i throw an idea and you um
well what about that and so now we're
we're chipping away and we're we're
refining this
this stone into something that is a
little bit more
refined a little bit more uh stable a
little bit more
beautiful in many respects and that is
just not something that you get from
someone
speechifying at you
that's true um and i think a lot of
traditional education
was just that you know maybe because
people didn't know better because they'd
like to hear themselves
talk you know or they felt like well i
had to sit there and shut up when i was
a student so now they're going to have
to sit there and shut up and listen to
me
oh there's a position at many colleges
called the reader
because they had these old texts and you
were
just there and you read it because there
was only one copy of the text and you
sat there
and everyone listened and maybe took
some notes or something and he read it
um so yeah that's the no i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna tell you a funny story
about
the middle ages and monks so in the
benedictine rule
and the benedictines were like the
biggest monastic order in the west for
quite a long time
um during meal times there would be like
a reader like you're saying and
everybody would like be sitting down
eating their stuff and you're supposed
to shut up and listen to whatever is
being
read because you know it's gonna be
edifying for you to always be some
spiritual book you know
and saint anselm somebody who i'm you
know particularly into
he um he when he was abbot he and when
he was archbishop of canterbury
he changed it once he had the authority
he was like
we're gonna talk we're we're to eat and
we're going to hear some
something red but then we're going to
discuss it we're not just going to like
passively absorb it
and you know if you think about it this
is really audacious because this goes
against the very rule
of the you know the monastic order that
he's in
i don't know i don't remember exactly
how he justified it but he came up with
some sort of justification
because he he liked to talk you know he
didn't just like to talk he liked to
talk with people he liked to find out
what was going
on with them so well let's let's talk
about
resources we've been promising this to
you for for quite a while
so we can we can talk about resources in
general and then we'll get in a little
bit deeper into it
a lot of resources are in fact generated
by academics
that others can use so like you know
great example that would be the history
with no gaps podcast one that i
particularly recommend but you know
organized by peter
adamson um really nice you know
um you're getting the benefit of
academics there's also
you know philosophy podcasts with a
whole variety of topics
that you can dip a toe into right as a
new school of thought as a guide to
digging into it with greater depth
there's also a ton of resources
developed by other people these days
and this is because the internet exists
right who are
not in academia who got interested in
philosophy and then thought
hey i want to i want to contribute i
i've got some competence i
can put some things in front of you
there's also an example that i
particularly like is uh what
philosophies this
okay yeah yeah and he's just a he's got
a very
good way what that is because a lot of
people probably don't know
it's a a podcast uh that he just
chooses a topic and he he does about
somewhere between half hour and 45
minute episodes so they're fairly easy
to
digest he'll bring either it's usually a
fairly high level sometimes he'll do
multi parts on a particular philosopher
but it's always
well produced and um at least
there's enough entertainment in the way
that he presents it that is
easy for me to like go into a new
topic that i'm totally unfamiliar with
and get at least a really
basic understanding oh that might be so
interesting that i will
go and pick up this author and start
digging into them more deeply
i think it's great that there are so
many people
who are not philosophy professors or
even may not have been philosophy majors
you know
may not have gone to college at all who
you know are willing to take the risk
of having other people say oh you're not
doing this right
to produce good stuff that that other
people
then share and recommend and
you know it's um it's really heartening
to see
because i'll tell you as somebody who's
been in traditional academia
if it was just all of those nerds we'd
really be at a disadvantage
[Laughter]
um so what were some i guess we've
talked a little bit
before but mooks moocs are still around
um
if you if you want to find them um that
those are what massive online
uh course yeah forget what the other o
was
it's been so long yeah uh
massive online was it open access
courses
yeah yeah there we go yeah and so
they're just a
a series of lectures um as well as
sometimes if they're good enough to have
associated uh
coursework and prompts for you to
actually work through uh if it's a
little bit more technically minded
they'll actually give you some like
problems to work yeah
which are great you know but there there
are a number
on philosophy but it does help to find a
professor that is
at least halfway entertaining yeah
that's too dry that is something
else i'll say about my peers is um it is
very much a mixed bag there there
are some people who are like born
lecturers speakers they can take any
topic and make it like super interesting
and then there's at the very other
extreme there are people who could take
the most interesting thing
and desiccate it you know and then
there's everything in between
some people are only good at talking
about like one topic and they stray into
other things
academics who try to who don't really
relate to ordinary people but try to
relate to ordinary people very often
quite cringey you know
to use one of the you know the kids
terms these days
let's go ahead and talk about about one
of the key kinds of resources philosophy
books philosophy books and articles
so yeah i mean they they really
are and i think a lot of people feel
themselves
at a disadvantage like well where can i
where can i get these do i have to like
buy a whole library and stock my
bookshelves and yeah you can do that if
you want to
but but you don't have to right there's
um yeah and actually let's i do want to
give a shout to three really great
local bookstores i don't know if you
frequent these i haven't been to the
third one for quite a long time
i'll admit because i don't get to the
airport but boswell's books
you know who who also is like a whole
community essentially you know they have
all sorts of great
um speaker series things and stuff like
that downtown books if you're into used
books
that is probably one of the best ones i
love their old building
it was amazing yeah oh you talking about
renaissance
well downtown but downtown also moved
what five years ago and they're they
used to have like four stories
and like two buildings worth of space
and it was
going into another world it was like
literally narnia for books
yeah now renaissance is kind of an
interesting one because
they're actually so there was there was
one that was outside of the airport
uh which unfortunately got condemned um
and then there's the airport bookstore
which has been amazing forever and it's
one of the little gems of the milwaukee
airport
and you don't actually have to like get
a boarding pass to go
check it out it's it's outside of the
secure area so some people
go to the airport park at the airport go
in to the bookstore
and frequent that so you know those are
if you're interested in buying books you
might check those out
boswells can order your books too you
don't have to go through amazon
but there's a a lot of other ways to get
philosophy books
you know we have a really
wonderful local library system the
milwaukee
central library has four different tiers
underground of
stacks and stacks of books the holdings
are actually so good that they
rival a lot of academic libraries and
you can
access anything within the system and if
you live outside of there
you know there's probably other library
systems that you belong to you may not
even know
until you start looking online you know
what you've got access to
one more uh physical location before we
go into one online
um philosophy departments
go to your local university there's
almost always a table full
of uh discarded it's like the philosophy
professor's like well i've got
three of uh aristotle's uh aesthetics
i don't need three of them put them out
on the door or on the table and if you
happen to know where those are
hey look there's some free books that's
right yeah
and that holds also for other humanities
departments english departments history
departments you know
um it's kind of a universal thing so
um what else um we got a number of
online opportunities here
and um so uh the first one is a lot of
material is in the public domain where
we're talking about philosophy
of philosophers that were around several
thousand years ago to all
all the way up to rather recent but like
anything over
at least 100 years is in the public
domain as well as a lot of the
translations
even of these things are also in the
public domain um
and and it's just it's free and easy to
just
go and look up the name of whatever
you're writing
and then put in pdf and google and all
of a sudden you've got that article
or that entire book or like um epub
is a open uh book format
yeah and like archive.org is another is
a place that you can you can search
within their holdings uh project
gutenberg
another important one um
what else audio versions of these um
like librivox i absolutely adore uh
because it's
all these people that like just get they
like like reading books
and so you can find all these classics
that are in the public domain
and so if you have a long commute and
you really want to start digging into
something
some philosophy some some philosophers
are much better for this is than others
like
i can listen to like plato's dialogues
uh a lot better than i can listen to
some one that's actually going through
act
or uh analytic philosophy or something
like that's really hard to keep
like i need to go back and read that
whereas if it's a dialogue it's a lot
easier to follow
you know i i really like hegel
you know gwf hegel but i remember
somebody telling me that they
listened to the phenomenology of spirit
in audiobook form and it wasn't librivox
it was a one that they purchased and i
was like i don't know how you would do
that
i haven't heard enough time just reading
it so yeah
dana's right some some things are better
heard than
than others you can get a lot of
articles online too
if you're interested in that google
scholar
fill papers academia there's a lot of
other
sites out there as well like dan was
saying you just put in
the article name and pdf and you can see
what comes up
you know and then there's also a number
of very
useful online encyclopedias like uh
what stanford's like plato.stanford or
sanford.plato yeah.org
the internet encyclopedia philosophy if
if one of them doesn't have it the other
one will
you know and often they'll both have it
so
and they're about equal in quality you
know
yeah it's a great uh overview for like
well what it was the kind of the basic
idea here if i don't
have the book on hand i can at least get
that and then it's like well i need to
dig into this more so go to the original
text
yeah and the the encyclopedia entries
can be very helpful
um for getting an idea of what to look
at
next there's other great resources
as well and again we live in a really
amazing time
where not only do we have this whole
internet right
but we have mobile technology so people
can get on a tablet or phone
and they can you know watch
more hours i mean there's there's more
hours of video out there than you could
possibly watch in your entire lifetime
20 lifetimes maybe maybe
4 000. i don't i don't i don't know you
know everybody
who knows how many videos that exist on
the internet you know well
i need to really shout out a really
great creator
this philosophy guy um dr greg sadler or
something
he's got a lot of videos out there
they're they're mostly about philosophy
but sometimes they're about captioning
and sort of on the side philosophy yeah
or walking around milwaukee yeah i mean
i'm only one of like
thousands of creators in the field of
philosophy i would say
you know there's there's so many other
people out there
you know and people will be like have
you seen so and so and i'll be like i i
only have time to shoot the videos i
don't have time to watch everybody
else's videos
so but yeah so videos podcasts
um i don't know how many philosophy
focused podcasts there are
but there's a lot of them we've already
just mentioned a few
right philosophize this history of
philosophy with no gaps
are there any others that you
particularly like i don't get a lot of
time to listen to
um there's a bbc philosophy
right right the whole bbc site has a
whole bunch of philosophy stuff
yeah they're they're pretty great with
that i'm just i've pulled out my
uh podcast app at the moment just to see
if there's anything that
um and uh philosophy now i think was
halfway decent um
yeah once again i i will also do the
history of philosophy without any gaps
is a great
um addendum and they also have another
one that's like
uh non-urocentric
right because the the original podcast
of without any gaps is is mostly
um western philosophy western western
with a little bit of
arabian because there's the back and
forth there yeah and then this is
there's another one that's like
basically uh afro and um
uh mostly far east china uh
in india yeah and so there's that whole
another whole area of philosophy that is
uh not often
read in at least the west here yeah they
they they're really doing a thorough job
and when they say with no gaps they mean
it they're not like leaving out
anybody all right that's why it's taking
them a while
they started over 10 years ago i
remember when when the
the series was just going and i was like
wow that's
that's a cool idea are they really going
to be able to see it through and they
have
so so what else online courses
there's a lot of uh online courses you
could take for free dan has mentioned
moocs there's also
smaller you know versions of classes
you can also purchase classes there's
plenty of that but
you don't necessarily need to and then
lots and lots of websites you know yeah
that thousand word philosophy is a nice
one that that came up recently these are
peer-reviewed articles
um specifically oriented to taking
philosophical ideas or problems
and presenting them in a thousand words
or less
and then there's communities of uh like
reddit or facebook or those are mostly
text-based but there's also some
um discord as a really interesting
platform if you actually want to have
discussions
yeah and if you can find a good a
discord community for philosophy or
especially if you've got one that's like
your jam of your little niche area
philosophy it's like if you like
phenomenology you can find a
phenomenology discord and just talk
about all that all day
all right great there's probably a place
for you and and
once again like we both really uh
promote dialogue as a way of learning
yeah it's
again i i've probably said this too many
times but
it's it's amazing what the internet has
afforded us the possibility to do
that 30 years ago was just science
fiction
you know for for people who want to
study philosophy
the resources are out there um
you know we mentioned the stoic
fellowship that's just one example of
uh groups that you know when we're not
in covid times actually meet face to
face that's that's a great way to
study philosophy with people
some of the other organizations that are
devoted to similar things
new acropolis which has a branch in
chicago
uh sophia which is the society
philosophers in america
mostly oriented around like public uh
discussions
um death cafes you might not have
thought of that
but they're pretty philosophical you
know i'm not even familiar what this is
it's a really cool organization the
whole idea behind it
is we're too worried about death and
we're too
um uptight about it so you there's
really very little um structure to it
you go in you sit down at tables have
some coffee with people and talk about
death
oh you know i think that's
i'd love to actually try that out yeah i
i've only been to one but it was it was
a good experience
nobody died you know um
then what else um you know there's
okay we talked about meetup as an
organization that allows you to actually
find that right because sometimes it
becomes difficult i guess you could find
these groups on facebook as well if you
can find a local group like that but um
and then you know there's conferences
both academic and and public and so
like uh greg and i have uh put on
a couple of uh well i guess one
together and then you've done others um
in person
uh meetups or conferences we did too uh
stoicon x milwaukee and then midwest
right
well in person yeah oh okay the midwest
was online but yes we did too yeah
yeah everything's got to be online for a
little while at least
um but yeah conferences are a great
place to meet people
that that are interested in what you're
interested in we should we should talk
about some of the
common um worries that people have and
i'm only going to bring up maybe one or
two of these
these are questions that people ask me
all the time about getting started with
philosophy
so one that i really want to zero in on
for people who are doing anything
academic my professor
program or whatever says i shouldn't
read x should i follow their advice
and my my answer is hey it's a free
country you know
you can read whatever the whatever you
want to you know you don't have to tell
your professor
or friend or whoever is like telling you
don't read
this or that and there's no there's no
philosophy book that's going to like
destroy your mind or
captivate you or suck you in like some
magic spell
you know i mean if you want to read ein
rand go right on ahead because you know
if
you'll probably get sick of it pretty
quick and be like ah a lot of this isn't
very good
um but she's not gonna like you know
automatically seduce you or if you want
to read noam chomsky way at the other
extreme that's fine too you know and
everything in between
you're not accountable to anybody but
yourself for what you want to read
and then you know what else what books
or thinkers should i start with well
whatever you can get your hands on
you know you don't have to begin with
plato or
or the pre-socratics you know i've got
to read heraclitus and parmenides
the first philosophy book i ever read
was camus myth
of sisyphus and i probably only
understood about 10 to 20
of what i was reading because i was 14
at the time
and it didn't kill me to start there
[Music]
you're gonna go back and re-read this
stuff anyway
there isn't any like set in stone
curriculum
that you have to follow if you're saying
go ahead
you're saying that you had to imagine
that uh greg as an early philosophy
student was happy
well i was happy i was okay fairly happy
kid we should talk about a practice real
quick and then jump into
our final thought yeah so our practice
for
today is try it on for size so many
flossers have many different
world views and values and it results in
certain prescribed actions that flow
from these first principles
so uh do as you know friedrich nietzsche
suggests
in his works and try on a philosophy as
a set of closing commit to it for a time
and see how it suits you
then try another it is one thing to just
read a book of philosophy
and a completely different thing to live
it
that's some great advice so we're going
to leave you
with the thoughts of somebody who i
guess you could say she's a philosopher
yeah um with the words of marjane
satrapi to educate myself
i had to understand everything starting
with myself
[Music]
you